[Music]
JLo is our video Vanguard she's bringing
an incredible performance that you can't
miss being acknowledged this way is
something that's that's really like
powerful to her and just her career and
she's such I'm just so excited for this
performance longer than the usual
performance MTV VMA boss is spilling on
Jennifer Lopez's performance at this
Sunday's show where the 49 year old will
also receive the Vanguard Award the VMAs
taped live in New York
JLo's hometown the hometown girl 100% we
met with JLo several months ago and you
know we told her that you know we had
made this decision that we wanted her to
be this year's video Vanguard and she
was unbelievably moved and and thrilled
and and it was extra special because
this conversation happened in the MTV
TRL studio so she was already feeling an
air of nostalgia then we relayed that
information on her it was just a really
nice heartfelt emotional moment
[Music]
she doesn't play like she brings it
she's so focused and it's gonna be one
of the most spectacular Vanguard
performances we were ever seen
[Music]